He asks: who has higher
fertility the group or individually selected
people in the uk and usa?
Well, based on a swedish study it's k strategy
that predicts fertility (in sweden at least,
and probably in the
uk and the usa too).
Since k strategy is associated with group
selectedness, I imagine it's something closer
to group selection
which predicts fertility.
And it's R strategy which is much more
individualistic, which predicts low fertility,
so we would say it's people that are more
group selected that are breeding, on that
indicator.
i don't think so.
I think that the
high k strategy morph, that is being selected
for, is actually particularly individually
selected.
what about the religiousness predicting fertility,
and they're group selected aren't they?
well actually, I've had a long discussion
on this, and the conclusion my colleagues
and i have come
to is that life history strategy particularly
among the high k end
is branchy, and people with slow life
histories are differentiated
behaviorally.
So there might be some morphs which are group
selected, and there are likely morphs
which are highly individually selected, and
it's likely you also get a mixture of both.
But i
suspect the ones (and this obviously is something
that needs to be tested), my suspicion is
that the
ones who are undergoing the fertility boom
at the moment, are the ones who are probably
highly individually selected.
And these would be ones who are adapted to
fitting into societal micro niches, and conforming
to structures around them.
This is among the K strategists, you're talking
about.
Yes, this would be among people with slow
life histories.
I don't think they're particularly group selected.
But what about the fact that religiousness
predicts fertility?
Well, I don't know if the religiousness that
people profess today is particularly group
selected.
I mean have you heard any particularly fiery
group selected Anglican sermons of late?
But that's not... they're nothing, they're
dying out.
Yes, but they're the mainline religion in
Britain.
And then you have protestants who are not
much better, who are the mainline religion
virtually everywhere else in the West.
The less said about the Catholics, the better
at this stage.
They're a mutated religion.
But the ones that are breeding above replacement
fertility, if you've got the Muslims, the
Mormons.
Ah, you're talking...
So I thought we're talking about just Europeans.
Right.
If you extend this to between group comparisons,
yes, I think you're looking at very strong
selection for group selected traits among
non-European people,
especially non-European people who are sharing
nations with European people.
But also the Mormons are doing well, and the
Amish because they have preserved a pre-industrial
lifestyle to some extent.
The Amish have very high rates of infant mortality.
Do you know that?
Well good, that means they're under purifying
selection.
Over 20 percent infant mortality based on
some estimates from the 70s.